has been a wild ride in washington for
president biden's plan for a new social
safety net and now it's hit another bump
for weeks west virginia senator joe
manchin has been demanding a lower price
tag and he got that but now he says he
needs to know more as more of the real
details outlined the basic framework are
released what i see are shell games
budget gimmicks that make the real cost
of the so-called 1.75 trillion dollar
bill
estimated to be
almost twice that amount
all right manchin is also upset that a
smaller infrastructure bill is yet to
pass he blames house progressives for
that and they blame conservative
democrats like him here now to break it
all down our chief washington
correspondent major garrett we are so
glad when we heard you were coming
yesterday we all did the whole year
can i just say i love what you've done
with the place
we're so glad you're here on this day in
particular okay joe manchin do you think
the white house has had it up to here
with him these days and how do you see
this all playing out so
the white house knows that democrats in
congress don't trust each other yeah
that's the biggest problem joe manchin
doesn't trust the progressives and the
progressives don't trust joe manchin
president biden has to be the trust
builder he has to say look i've given
everyone lots of time to go over the
details the numbers and the legislative
language
but i've got to blow the whistle nate
you know what happens when the whistle
blows the place stops that's right
everyone knows what to do next yep line
up for the next play the next play is to
vote the next play is to vote and decide
on both these initiatives so the biden
domestic agenda can have something
that's lacked for weeks and weeks and
weeks so what clarity
why doesn't he blow the whistle then the
president has to make that decision
himself and those around him have to say
mr president now is the time he has had
that opportunity before and has let it
pass
at some point you have to say
it's time to vote and time to clarify
what's actually at stake and important
things are at stake i don't want to
suggest democrats are simply bickering
over trivia they're not home health care
via medicaid for the sandwich generation
for their elderly parents is a huge deal
universal pre-k is a huge deal these are
monumental changes and how they happen
and at what speed and at what price tag
matter a great deal that's why they
continue to negotiate but at some point
you've got to say let's move forward
define what we've done and begin to
explain it to the country that's going
to receive so on the subject of at some
point is there any kind of natural
barrier or deadline or can democrats
keep pushing this down the calendar
infinitely not infinitely uh
determined yes yes uh practical time is
flexible as democrats have proved terry
mcauliffe was begging for three weeks
vote on infrastructure give me a win in
virginia so i can point to democrats
governing in a way that is coherent
meaningful and responsive he didn't get
that progressive said you know what run
on what we've already done terry
mccullough said no no i want
infrastructure if he loses that race in
virginia and he very well might one of
the reasons not the only reason but one
of the reasons will be democrats failing
to define what governing looks like so
to your point they could take this
another week
there is a december 3rd deadline on the
continuing resolution to keep the
government open and extend the debt
ceiling they could go there i've watched
congresses take it all the way to
christmas
until the president says
folks
we've talked we've negotiated lock arms
vote pass it we're going to continue to
move down this sort of
era of
drift and disorganization two words that
don't work don't work well for democrats
who work very well for republicans now
there's other key elections going on
around the country what are you watching
out for other thing i'm keeping an eye
on is the new jersey governor's race
should not be close it is closer than
you would think based on the blue state
history of new jersey education has been
the issue that has galvanized republican
voters in virginia and new jersey if
glenn younkin wins in virginia against
terry mcauliffe and this race in new
jersey is close republicans will take
that education issue and run with it
harder in the midterm so i'm keeping a
very close eye on new jersey all right
major we're keeping a very close eye on
you thank you for coming to have you
yeah it really is i love seeing major
garrett